ahora que ya sabemos sobre grupos
funcionales vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar algunos de estos grupos en en
moléculas orgánicas que de verdad
existen que son reales y vamos a empezar
con la aspirina y cuyo otro nombre para
la aspirina es el ácido acetilsalicílico
ok así que debe haber al menos un ácido
presente en esta molécula de aspirina y
estudiamos que una una ha sido digamos
estudiamos un ácido en él en el vídeo
anterior
de grupos funcionales y ese grupo
funcional se llamaba ácidos carboxílicos
que está contenido déjenme déjenme lo
voy marcando está contenido justamente
aquí verdad cuando tenemos un enlace
doble de un carbono con un oxígeno unido
a un grupo r y aún a un o h verdad es
decir esta parte de aquí esta parte de
aquí es la parte del ácido carboxílicos
muy bien si ahora nos fijamos en esta
otra parte de la molécula digamos esta
que tenemos aquí
aquí podemos notar que también hay un
hay un grupo carbón y lo de en este lado
es decir es el carbono unido a un
oxígeno con un enlace doble pero aquí en
vez de estar unido a 1 h simplemente
está unido a un oxígeno que después está
unido aún a un grupo funcional o al
resto de la molécula verdad que no es un
hidrógeno y de igual forma del otro lado
hay un grupo r entonces de este otro
lado tenemos un este
grupo funcional esther y la gran
diferencia es esencialmente esa verdad
si el oxígeno con el enlace sencillo
está unido únicamente a un hidrógeno
entonces tenemos un grupo ácido
carbónico carboxílicos perdón si ese
oxígeno está unido a otro grupo
funcional con carbonos y demás entonces
es un este es la gran diferencia muy
bien y podemos encontrar un último grupo
funcional que es este de aquí que es
bien fácil de ubicar que no es otra cosa
más que un anillo aromático verdad este
es un anillo aromático y que de hecho
también
digamos podríamos decir que es un al que
no no es exactamente un al que no digo a
pesar de que tiene los enlaces dobles
pero lo ubicamos en un grupo funcional
distinto justamente por su estructura
cíclica y a éste también se le conocía
como harén o ya habíamos dicho que se le
desearé no justamente tomaba la parte
digamos ar
de aromático y heno de que era digamos
un al que no aunque aunque no es
precisamente un al que no pero si se
distingue por sus enlaces dobles muy
bien entonces éste fue la
molécula de la aspirina vamos a ver otro
ejemplo en este ejemplo de aquí es mucho
más complicado y éste o se los presentó
es la amoxicilina que es por cierto un
derivado de la penicilina y todos los
derivados de la penicilina funcionan
esencialmente como antibióticos ese y
buenos difieren que será por uno o dos
grupos funcionales muy bien entonces ahí
tenemos la amoxicilina vamos a tratar de
ubicar todos los grupos
todos los grupos funcionales que se
encuentran presentes en esta molécula y
vamos a empezar con aquel grupo que se
encuentra en todos los derivados de la
penicilina que es exactamente este de
aquí verdad tenemos un grupo carbón y lo
unido a un nitrógeno pero ese nitrógeno
después está unido a otros grupos
funcionales así que esto como ya
habíamos visto en el vídeo anterior es
justamente una amiga verdad esta es la
parte que tienen en común todos los
derivados de la penicilina vamos a ver
qué es lo que tenemos por aquí
aquí tenemos justamente como en el
ejemplo anterior un ácido carboxílicos
verdad tenemos un ácido carboxílicos muy
bien ahora esta parte de acá arriba es
fácilmente ubicable verdad tenemos un
azufre unido a dos grupos r al digamos a
dos otros grupos funcionales y éste se
le conocía al grupo de los sulfuros el
sub sulfuro verdad muy bien qué otra
cosa podríamos ubicar de esta molécula
aquí tenemos esta estructura muy muy muy
peculiar que tiene un nitrógeno tiene
enlaces dobles en fin esto esto de aquí
también es una unidad verdad y hay que
tener mucho cuidado uno podría pensar
que esto de aquí sería una mina pero no
lo es justamente por este carbono que
tenemos aquí este nitrógeno está unido a
otro grupo funcional r con carbono es
verdad entonces esto de aquí también es
una medida pero justamente y por eso me
gusta mucho este ejemplo porque de este
otro lado tenemos nh 2 verdad tenemos
esta parte esta parte de aquí aunque se
parece mucho a la
alameda que por cierto dije dije algo
que estaba mal y como el nitrógeno
estaba unido a un ácido carboxílicos es
por eso que se le conoce como amiga no
no tenía nada que ver este carbono
disculpen la confusión este sí es una
amina una amina y esto es justamente
porque el nitrógeno no está unido a
ningún grupo a ningún ácido carboxílicos
verdad no más ganar ningún grupo carbón
hilo muy bien entonces ahí tienen
ustedes una mina y nuevamente tenemos a
este amigo que ya conocemos muy bien
un anillo aromático verdad este es un
anillo
aromático que ya vimos en incluso en el
ejemplo anterior y finalmente tenemos
esta terminación que es un h digamos que
también se le conoce como un hidroxilo
hidroxilo muy bien
hidroxilo y es parte de los alcoholes
esto es parte de los alcoholes ahora
esto tiene un nombre muy muy muy
particular justamente porque estamos
poniendo alcoholes con aromático muy
bien entonces cuando unimos una
terminación digamos
a un anillo aromático entonces se le
conoce como fenol muy bien es un freno
lee de hecho es esto es especial
justamente por estar con el anillo
aromático y son muy comunes en la
naturaleza son muy comunes en la
naturaleza entonces ya logramos
distinguir todos los grupos funcionales
presentes en la amoxicilina vamos a ver
unos últimos dos ejemplos más
ahí tienen ustedes las moléculas de la
morfina y de la codeína muy bien
entonces vamos a hacer lo mismo vamos a
tratar de ubicar todos los grupos
funcionales de aquí
entonces empecemos con la morfina por
ejemplo aquí en este lado tenemos bien
ubicado nuestro anillo aromático tenemos
nuestro anillo aromático y podemos notar
que también tenemos una terminación de
terminación hidroxilo aquí que lo
convierte también en un grupo de alcohol
es verdad es un grupo de los alcoholes
entones es una parte del grupo de los
alcoholes y justamente por tener esta
combinación se le conoce como fenol como
vimos en el ejemplo anterior ahora bien
aquí tenemos un oxígeno con dos grupos
funcionales en cada lado ya éste se le
conocía como éter verdad este es un éter
muy bien ahora nuevamente tenemos aquí
un grupo alcohol verdad un hidroxilo de
este lado y tenemos un doble enlace en
este anillo pero a diferencia de los
ejemplos anteriores sólo es uno así que
aquí justamente
justamente aquí tenemos un al que no
verdad los al que no se distinguen
justamente por estos enlaces dobles por
otro lado tenemos aquí este nitrógeno
que está unido a dos grupos
funcionales y habíamos cometido una
equivocación o una confusión en el
ejemplo anterior este por no estar unido
a ningún ácido carboxílicos se le conoce
como amina verdad justamente esta es la
amina y ya tenemos todos los grupos
funcionales de esta molécula que es la
morfina que por cierto su nombre
justamente toma la terminación y nada
por tener una amina y digamos la parte
de morse viene de en realidad del dios
griego morfeo que es el dios de los
sueños y justamente si uno toma mucho
mucha morfina pues soñarás mucho y es
muy peligroso en concentraciones altas
ahora otro problema que tiene la morfina
es que es sumamente adictiva ahora por
otro lado tenemos la codeína y que si
nos damos cuenta tenemos los mismos
grupos funcionales aquí el anillo normal
o el éter este alcohol este al que no
está amina pero lo que cambia
radicalmente aquí es justamente la
presencia de este éter verdad cambiamos
un alcohol por un éter y eso es lo que
hace que sean esencialmente dos
moléculas distintas muy bien ahora bien
la codeína no es tan efectiva como como
digamos para eliminar los dolores como
lo es la morfina pero también no es tan
adictiva así que la codeína puede ser
usada para el dolor cuando no es
extremadamente severo y esto nos permite
disminuir el riesgo de la adicción hasta
ahora hemos estudiado un montón de
moléculas y hemos encontrado muchos
grupos funcionales en la práctica
deberías poder ubicarlo de muchas otras
moléculas orgánicas justo como lo hemos
hecho ahora por ejemplo circulando los
grupos funcionales